it is over 11.
your friends
have laws we all know vacna is
absolutely terrifying both on and off
the screen the fear was genuine
definitely very real i was terrified but
did you know he had over a dozen
different looks
number one armor like vecta's not strong
enough already one scrapped design was
inspired by a prehistoric fish named the
dunkleosteus
this massive fish swam through the ocean
with rock hard bony plates covering its
face and jaw it was also super
terrifying it was supposed to be assumed
that henry had spent so long in the
upside down that his skin had grown hard
in a protective armor-like way the
exposed flesh that is pale is a human
skin that hasn't seen sunlight for the
last 20 years number two we definitely
would have stocked up on raid this fekna
design didn't make the cut because it
would have been difficult to pull off in
a practical way as we know the duffer
brothers prefer to do as much as they
can practically our current vechna is
pretty much all practical michael marr
jr describes this version like some sort
of praying mantis this one leaned more
towards an insect it would have been
much taller the legs and arms would have
had the ability to split apart the chest
would have opened up number three we
know the duffer brothers are huge fans
of the alien films this look definitely
goes for more of a classic otherworldly
scare factor than our current fechna
this was michael marr jr's thinking
behind this look the thinking was that
the upside down would have transformed
him over time into something closer to a
demogorgon than a human again this one
was scrapped because it limited henry's
facial expressions number four but the
real question is would he turn into one
of those demo bats
apparently in the early versions of the
season 4 scripts vecna was depicted as
being super pale like a vampire it makes
sense given the fact that there aren't a
lot of sunny beaches to catch a tan on
in the upside down based on that michael
marr jr pitched a bit of an alternative
look for vechna i pitched that the skin
might actually be rotting away if
someone was forced to live in the upside
down for too long perhaps he would try
and clamp the skin together to save it
number 5. it gives a whole new meaning
to the term facelift in michael marr
jr's tick-tock video he goes over a few
of these nightmare-inducing vector
designs that in the majority of them
have skin hanging off of his face due to
the long-time exposure from the upside
down his skin would have started to come
off in patches in one design all of the
skin was hanging off of his jaw exposing
the bloody decayed flesh beneath number
six another favorite from the duffer
brothers film inspiration this version
of vecna had a patchwork of skin
stretched over his body definitely a
inspired figure in the 1987 film frank
the antagonist comes back from the dead
in this bloody monstrous condition until
he starts to consume his victims and
regenerate one thing that remains
similar to our final cut vector though
is his signature long clawed hand matt
and ross were very clear that they
wanted this large distorted hand
number seven it's giving voldemort vibes
as michael maher jr words it he was
considering a cloak and also playing
with a polio type of gangrene if you
look closely at this design you can see
similarities within the face of the
final cut of vecna particularly in the
mouth and his lack of nose who do you
think would win in a battle vecna or
voldemort let us know in the comments
number eight we're starting to see where
the vines came from this design
emphasizes an oversized left arm with a
protruding tentacle the concept behind
this was after spending so long in the
upside down henry's body would have
gotten infected with some sort of
tumorous gangrene that would eat away at
vecna's flesh though this design was
discarded it definitely paved the way
for all the scary appendages that vecna
sported throughout the season number
nine yeah we definitely prefer the vines
it seems like the big theme of some of
these early designs was the upside down
slowly rotting away henry's flesh
michael marr jr describes it as follows
early iterations of vechna had maggots
infesting the cavity of his missing nose
as well as wiggling in the rot of his
vine infected body parts number 10. of
course predator has to be included in
the vechna designs not only is vecna a
vicious predator himself
i saw a means to realize my potential
but the idea behind him was that he was
one of those villains that never runs
after his victims because he doesn't
need to to become
the predator i was always born to be
when trying to explore the structure of
his face and body that would depict such
a villain this design was scrapped
because it was too much like predator
number eleven no big deal just more
terrifying decay this is another
upside-down decay-influenced design
henry's body definitely endures some
massive transformations throughout his
time down there compared to vecna's pale
skin the radiation rot would be an
unsettling bright red in contrast though
they were definitely nightmare-worthy
they found that they didn't disguise
vechna's true identity well enough they
didn't want the audience to think the
mild-mannered orderly henry could
possibly be the series major villain
maybe we'll save that story for another
day
it doesn't have a happy ending i'm
afraid number 12 do you think final cut
factna was tall enough one of the
earliest iterations of vecna depicted
his long gaunt body as being much taller
than the one we got to see everything
about his body would have been expanded
including a mutilated viney neck also
throughout the early envisionings of
vecna most of the designs still had hair
on his head eventually throughout all
the different transformations they ended
up doing away with that
number 13. this one is serving
nightmares even michael marr jr says
he's not quite sure what he was thinking
on this one
this design of vechna even sports some
spiky hands and shoulders just to add
that extra touch of horrifying it's safe
to say that this design doesn't hold a
ton of human elements to it when
somebody is filled with so much rage and
so much resentment they definitely
wouldn't be sporting a 24 7 smile
the human element's gone
number 14. somehow this makes us
appreciate the casual less scary
nosebleed in these early skin hanging
designs one of them showed vecna with
melted skin covering his eyeballs
according to michael marr jr for this
specific design he wanted vecna to cry
tears of blood every time his powers
were used the reason why these designs
were cut was actually that it limited
vechna's ability to utilize his face for
an emotional purpose this brings us to
one of the most important scare factors
the duffer brothers needed to implement
into vechna's character number 15 we'll
be seeing them in our nightmares for
weeks we talked a little bit about why
some of the designs were scrapped quite
a few due to the fact that we couldn't
see jaime campbell bauer's facial
movements that was a major development
when going through all of these
villainous depictions all in all the
more human version of vecna that we
ended up with was directly correlated to
the fact that the duffer brothers wanted
us to see vacna sneering and smiling as
he tortured his victims you're going to
look absolutely beautiful
we've got alien predator hellraiser
maggots tears of blood hanging skin and
honestly way too much horror for us to
process right now that was so cool that
was so awesome we'll be having our own
nightmares full of alternate vector
designs for weeks to come
what's your favorite vechna design